[Musique]
le point commun qu'on a ici c'est qu'on
est tous révoltés et qu'on pense que la
société on peut toujours la changer et
l'autre point commun qu'on a c'est que
depuis cinq ans on se mobilise les uns
et les autres pour développer des
bagarres et des résistances face à la
droite donc c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
rassemblé que qu'on va essayer de
redonner la parole aux uns et aux autres
à la fois sur ce qu'ils ont fait et puis
sur ce qui reste à faire quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans cette campagne on essaye de le
mettre sur la bonne voie que j'aime bien
la droite mais aussi aujourd'hui on vous
voit la gauche sait les problèmes
d'insécurité et d'immigration beaucoup
de responsables politiques qui remarque
2007 ce soit de nouveau 2002 et qu'on
parle que d'un sécurité du matin
jusqu'au soir avec en plus une variante
sur l'identité nationale et
l'intégration la marseillaise le drapeau
bleu blanc rouge et compagnie alors que
la droite et l'extrême droite fasse ça
c'est pas franchement surprenant parce
que c'est un moyen ne pas répondre aux
questions sociales qui sont posées par
les mobilisations sociales dont on parle
depuis le début mai que ça vienne de la
gauche c'est quand même plus surprenant
quoi aujourd'hui on constate qu'un des
problèmes pour les retraites c'est que
déjà les fameuses annuités nécessaires
pour avoir une retraite à taux plein et
ben on est de moins en moins à pouvoir y
arriver et maintenant les retraités
c'est un des secteurs de la population
où on note l'apparition de poches de
pauvreté le minimum vieillesse
aujourd'hui c'est environ 620 euros par
mois donc c'est très faible et je crois
que la revendication d'une
revalorisation de 300 euros pour tous
est revenu c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est très nécessaire dans une grande
entreprise comme la nôtre qui est le
quatrième constructeur mondial de
véhicules
eh ben on a des gens qui travaillent par
intermittence puisqu'on a eu l'exemple
de sandouville avec des gens qui ont eu
70 jours de chômage et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui bas effectivement ces
gens là ont un problème aussi de
logements puisque beaucoup de jeunes
avaient pris leur logement et leur
indépendance qui avait été embauché chez
renault qui aujourd'hui sont obligés de
retourner chez leurs parents avec des
salaires de misère parce qu'ils ont
perdu en moyenne depuis 2000 euros sur
l'année dernière sur les conditions de
travail c'est vrai pour les pour les
plus anciens mais c'est vrai aussi pour
les plus jeunes
voilà au début on arrive dans un job ou
dans un boulot on fait le tout fou on
court après les heures sup
on essaie de gratter le manque de
salaire avec des heures supplémentaires
et et puis au bout de dix ans on
commence à se dire que voilà la charge
de boulot est de plus en plus pénible
moi je travaille dans une boîte de
l'ascenseur on se fait de trois mois par
an alors dans une dans une branche qui
est tout petit
pourquoi parce que l'école ils sont
rares ils sont terriblement dégradée
notamment pression sur le travail et la
sécurité au travail c'est deux morts par
accidents de travail par jour huit morts
par l'amiante par jour et ces morts là
on n'en parle jamais parce que si jamais
des prolos quoi sur les salaires on a
besoin aussi
deux représentations du mérite et de ce
que les gens donnent pour l'entreprise
et que si vous voulez encore faire
d'ironie 1500 euros bruts dans cinq ans
moi ça me va pas on n'a pas un point de
vue pleurnichard sur la société on
demande simplement notre dû le respect
auquel on a droit puisque c'est 90% de
la population qui fabrique des biens des
richesses des services et qu'on voit
finalement jamais la couleur
aujourd'hui j'habite en banlieue
parisienne pour lé logement ils ont
augmenté quasiment de 50% en 10 ans et
les salaires ils ont pas augmenté de ce
film pour ça en disant fait c'est vrai
et je crois que le problème du logement
c'est aujourd'hui un problème
fondamental et quand on est dans une
société où il ya des des centaines de
milliers de logements vacants et que par
ailleurs on a des gens qui dorment dans
la rue et il ya quand même un truc qui
tourne pas rond quoi tout ce que vous
racontez à nous c'est notre avenir le
cpe ça a été la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase en plus de tout ça on
nous proposait de nous jeter à n'importe
quel moment comme un simple kleenex
quoique non parce que ouais ya un
certain nombre de mesures qui pour les
jeunes permettra d'améliorer notre notre
situation quotidienne que ce soit une
allocation d'autonomie pour tous les
jeunes bas qui permettrait justement
qu'on ne soit pas obligé de tafer en
plus en plus d'aller encore un match de
travail 17h30 par semaine en plus de mes
25 heures de cours au bout d'un moment
voilà quoi la semaine ça devient
compliqué faut effectivement des revenus
plus importants pour vivre mieux mais
quelque part effectivement on parle
beaucoup de
la petite enfance ou le quatrième âge
etc c'est à dire un certain nombre de
services publics à développer ou à
reconquérir il faut vraiment prendre le
service public comme les garanties
garantie minimum est garanti quand même
qu effectivement on a tous accès quelles
que soient les territoires quels que
soient les âges
quelles que soient les professions au
moins ou bien commun on sait encore
bagarrer dans un hôpital récemment dans
le service de psychiatrie parce qu'il
voulait supprimer encore six postes et
on s'aperçoit que bon toutou les tous
les pans qui sont intéressants vos privé
et puis dans le public on garde bien sûr
toutes les toutes les contraintes tout
ce qu'elle accueille 24 heures sur 24
toutes les urgences il faut entendre à
chaque fois la souffrance des soignants
qui disent on peut pas donner la qualité
de soins qu'on voudrait donner aux gens
et ça c'est vraiment insupportable
on est plus en plus nombreux à accepter
un minimum de serrer la ceinture ce soit
dans nos conditions de travail que ce
soit dans les baisses de rémunération
les blocages de rémunération ou et où
les prestations sociales qui diminue
parce que venant qu'on nous dise tilt
dans la tête c'est le fait que la france
s'appauvrit ray et qui aurait plus les
moyens finalement de vivre correctement
ni au boulot ni dans la vie de tous les
jours
or voilà le problème c'est que des
richesses si on n'a jamais eu autant en
france qu'en ce moment et la
redistribution de ces richesses l a
jamais été aussi inégalitaire qu'en ce
moment on est chacun dans notre coin que
ce soit au service public dans le privé
ou quotidien amener des bagarres un
petit peu séparément parfois tous
ensemble avec ou sans victoire mais une
chose qui est claire c'est quel que soit
le gouvernement qui sortira des urnes
les bagarres faudra continuer à les
mener donc ce vote pour nous c'est aussi
un encouragement lutte à toutes les
luttes qu'on a mené qu'on parlait à des
tas de personnes et celles qui devront
être menés dans les cinq prochaines
années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]